kamala harris pushes back and reports
she was quote
set up to fail and suggesting anyone who
dares to criticize her is racist and
sexist
no i don't believe i'm being set up to
fail
but
um because these are more democrats but
but more important
i'm vice president united states
anything that
i handle
is because it's a tough issue
and it couldn't be handled at some other
level is the fact that you're a woman
and the fact that you are a minority in
this office
part of why there is such scrutiny
i'll leave that
for others to deal with i you know i i
have a job to do
and i'm going to get that job done
and so much for the border crisis here's
what the vp says is her biggest failure
what do you think your biggest failure
has been at this point
to not get out of dc more
i mean
and i actually mean that sincerely
katie help me out here i
you know she's has horrible issues with
her image
uh the movie child movie hood actors
classroom setting didn't quite go to
plan
isn't it and you and i kind of from this
cut from the same cloth the only way you
improve your
view in the public is by accountability
and the deeds that you do that are
successful
can she ever
give us that or is it just too much to
even think about or wish for
well for first i would say her biggest
failure is not getting that laugh under
control when she's asked serious
questions during interviews and that
that question from margaret brennan was
so leading and biased to say well are
you basically sure that it's not because
you're a woman and a woman of color
have they been paying attention to the
trump administration the way the media
treated president trump who was a a
white male
you know kamala harris had an
opportunity here she made history she
has an opportunity to make something of
that history and instead she's sitting
back and acting like she's some kind of
victim instead of digging into the
issues you know she's been given a
portfolio of very serious topics and yet
has done hardly anything to make it work
and to become successful and it's
because kamala harris was a pick from
joe biden as a gift to the far left
let's not forget she was the most
liberal senator in the senate she even
beat bernie sanders back in the day and
he needed that kind of base to get him
across the finish line in november which
is why he picked her among other issues
and so
you know she has an opportunity here to
really do some good with her office and
yet she's just turning around and
basically throwing up her hands and
saying well i'm not being treated well
because i'm a woman and because i'm a
woman of color and that's just not true
she hasn't delivered results on the
portfolio that the president has given
her
you know you know jason it it's
astounding to me i don't ever remember
hearing barack obama ever uh play that
word an excuse for not getting things
done and and my grandmother always used
to told me it's you know it's not what's
there you're called or what happens to
you it's what you do with it
when you think about how you can fix
problems you can never fix the problem
if it's always the
imaginary monster if it's always racism
it's always sexism there's no really to
gauge that when does that stop doesn't
that just hurt the democratic party when
accountability is right there
uh absolutely it totally does look her
her biggest failure is that she has no
accomplishments and her biggest failure
is the fact that she said she was the
last one in the room talking to joe
biden before they made that incredibly
botched
attempt at extraction of our troops out
of afghanistan she's given the the
border assignment and yet you talk to
henry cuellar a democrat a democrat
whose congressional district encompasses
about 200 miles of the of the border
with mexico and even he says she seems
totally disinterested can't even get her
to return a call to a democratic
congressman so you go down the list the
guatemalan president said yeah she came
and visited then i haven't heard from
her since july uh the the list goes long
and she her number one chore quite
frankly
given that she was a former united
states senator was to help usher through
the president's agenda through the
senate in the house and they have all
democrats pence did that for trump
cheney did that for bush but i gotta
tell you kamala harris i cannot figure
what she's doing other than sending her
own staff to get psychological help
because they feel so so hit
by by kamala harris
you know richard let me let me ask you
if you were sitting in a table right now
with her to give her advice to how to
turn around this whole image thing and
and get get the american people back on
board what would your first sentence be
i think that you need to do more
interviews like we saw
oh sorry i thought it was richard
yeah right yeah it was you bro
oh okay listen i think there's a couple
things here i think the first thing
she's got to do is do more interviews
like the one we just saw her do this
past weekend with margaret benner but i
do think that she actually has to engage
journalists who are who speak to the
democratic base right we know the
democratic base the most loyal
democratic voter is a black woman so why
isn't she talking to folks like harris
faulkner why isn't she having interviews
with yamiche alcindor why isn't she
sitting down with april ryan and and
tamron hall and other black female
journalists that so she could begin to
have accomplished with black america and
i think the first thing she says in that
conversation is she apologizes for this
white house's mistreatment of haitian
refugees at the southern border of the
united states that's why a lot of
african-american voters have
consternation with the vice president's
office because she's in charge for the
border and i do think those
african-american voters are looking for
answers
rachel final thoughts take it home yeah
well i'm just going to respond to what
richard said her problem isn't with
black voters they may be not happy with
her or embarrassed by the poll numbers
that the biden administration and harris
harris
vice president harris has right now as
the first black
vp but they're going to vote for her the
real problem that this administration
and kamala harris in particularly has is
with hispanic voters they are bleeding
hispanic voters they will not win any
future election without them and part of
the problem a big part of that problem
is what is happening at our border
a lot of hispanics live along that
border they know exactly what happens
they deal with the dead bodies in their
ranches they deal with the crime wave
the sex trafficking the the jobs they
lost building our wall infrastructure
jobs that they lost as they see panels
rusting yeah she could get out of dc and
visit with those hispanics because
they're going to lose the next election
if they don't get those hispanics back
on track i don't see them making any
attempts to do that enough said on that
one coming up it's a red state boom why
are thousands saying sauronara to the
liberal blue states
[Music]
[Music]
has so many new footlongs here's how
they line up we got the new chicken and
bacon ranch new baja steak and jack and
the new baja chicken and bacon aka the
smoke show say big order through the app
i'm dr brendan white i've been an
optometrist for 29 years now i started
taking balance of nature fruits and
vegetables 20 something years ago and
i've been taking it ever since
my practice is called envision eye
health we're all about preventative eye
care one of the things established from
eye research is fruits and vegetables
are good for our eye health so i've
always liked balance of nature from that
sense and the concept is clear from the
title this is the way our nutrition was
meant to be acquired through fruits and
vegetables so my favorite question i get
when i'm working in my clinic is doctor
well what do you do and i tell them i
take balance of nature
it's a great product and i can't think
of another product that has a more broad
reaching scale of things that it can
improve in our health start your journey
to better health call 1-800-246-8751
or go to balanceofnature.com and don't
forget to get 35 off your first
preferred order by using discount code
fox news
[Music]
impossible to know
[Music]
priceline can help you make the most of
your budget saving you up to 40 on your
flight ooh we have a comment from the
airport announcers
what
[Music]
every trip is a big deal
this is kate
she always wanted her smile to shine
now she uses a capful of thera-breath
healthy smile oral rinse to give her the
healthy sparkly smile she always wanted
[Music]
thera breath it's a better mouthwash at
walmart target and other fine stores
it's the nutrisystem 50th anniversary
celebration to celebrate this
anniversary nutrisystem has a limited
time special deal for you get 50 off a
month of meals and 50 off a month of new
low glycemic shakes to sustain energy
and crush hunger and get premium meals
that are 50 percent bigger with up to 30
grams of protein happy 50th anniversary
nutrisystem i never thought i could lose
so much weight but i did it thanks for
changing my life you think you know
nutrisystem think again get new
restaurant babes that tastes like your
favorite restaurant delivered to your
door it's a high protein low glycemic
approach to help you keep your blood
sugar levels steady think of all the
diets that have come and gone the fads
the magic pills the books the apps you
know who's still helping people lose
millions of pounds
nutrisystem go online or call right now
go online or call 888 908 thin to get 50
off on a month of meals and shakes
[Music]
you can feel it
[Music]
unwrap all our holiday channels with a
very merry offer
when you use constant contact
prepare accordingly
let's win this with email marketing and
more to drive your business forward try
it free at constantcontact.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]